من
وم
وم ال
[Silence]
ول
ف الصلا
[Silence]
فاولئك
يدخلون يمون
شيء التي ويبيها
[Silence]
وعشيا تلك
الجنه التي نورث من عبادنا من كان
تقيا وما نتنزل الا باذن ربك له ما بين
ايدينا وما خلفنا وما بين
ذلك وما نتنزل الا بامر ربك له ما بين يد
ايدينا وما خلفنا وما بين ذلك وما كان ربك
نسيا رب السماوات والارض وما بينهما
فاعبده واصطبر
لعبادته فاعبده واصطبر
لعبادته هل تعلم له سميا
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
و
استقيم
اعتدل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك ن نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ويقول الانسان ائذا ما مت لسوف اخرج
حيا اولا يذكر الانسان انا خلقناه من قبل
ولم يك
شيئا فوربك لنحشرنهم
والشياطين ثم لنحضرنهم حول جهنم
جثيا ثم
لننزعن من كل شيعه ايهم اشد على الرحمن
عتيا ثم لنحن اعلم بالذين هم اولى بها
صليا وان
منكم الا واردها كان على ربك حتما
مقضيا ثم ننجي الذين اتقوا ونذر الظالمين
فيها جثيا واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا
بينات قال الذين كفروا قال الذين كفروا
للذين امنوا اي
الفريقين اي الفريقين اي الفريقين خير
مقاما واحسن
نديا وكم اهلكنا قبلهم من قرن هم وكم
اهلكنا قبلهم من قرن هم احسن احسن اثاثا
ورئيا قل من كان في ضلاله فليمدد له
الرحمن
مدا حتى اذا راوا ما يوعدون اما العذاب
واما الساعه فسيعلمون من هو خشر مكانا
واضعف
جندا ويزيد الله الذين اهتدوا
هدى
والباقيات الصالحات خير عند ربك
ثوابا وخيرا
مردا افرايت الذي كفر باياتنا وقال
لاوتين مالا وولدا اطلع الغيب ام اتخذ عند
الرحمن
عهدا كلا سنكتب ما يقول ونمد له من العذاب
مدا ثه ما يقول وياتينا فردا واتخذوا من
دون الله الهه ليكونوا لهم
عزا كلا سيكفرون
بعبادتهم ويكونون عليهم
ضدا الم تر انا ارسلنا الشياطين على
الكافرين تؤزهم ازا ف لا تعجل عليهم
انما نعد لهم عدا يوم نحشر المتقين الى
الرحمن وفدا ونسوق المجرمين الى
جهنم
وردا لا يملكون الشفاعه الا من اذن له الا
من اتخذ عند الرحمن
عهدا وقالوا اتخذ الرحمن
ولدا لقد جئتم شيئا
ادا تكاد السماوات يتفطرن منه
وتنشق الارض وتخر الجبال هدا ان دعوا
للرحمن ولدا وما ينبغي للرحمن ان يتخذ
ولدا
ان كل من في السماوات والارض الا ات
الرحمن عبدا لقد احصاهم وعدهم عدا وكلهم
اتيه يوم القيامه
فردا
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات سيجعل لهم
الرحمن
ودا فانما يسرناه بلسانك لتبشر به
المتقين لتبشر به المتقين
وتنذر به قوما لدا وكم اهلكنا قبلهم من
قرن هل تحس منهم من
احد هل تحس منهم من احد او تسمع لهم
ركزا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الد دين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
طه ما انزلنا عليك القران لتشقى الا تذكره
لمن يخشى
تنزيلا ممن خلق الارض والسماوات
العلى الرحمن على العرش
استوى له ما في السماوات وما في الارض وما
بينهما وما تحت الثرا وان تجهر بالقول
فانه يعلم السر
واخفاه الله لا اله الا هو
الاسماء الحسنى وهل اتاك حديث
موسى اذ راى نارا فقال لاهلهم ثوا اني
انست نارا لعلي اتيكم منها بقبس او اجد
على النار هدى
فلما اتاها نودي يا موسى
اني انا ربك فاخلع عليك انك بالواد المقدس
طوى وانا اخترتك فاستمع لما يوحى
انني انا الله لا اله الا انا فاعبدني
واقم الصلاه
لذكري ان الساعه اتيه اكاد اخفي فيها
لتجزى كل نفس فلا
يصدنك عنها من لا يؤمن بها
واتبع تلك بيمينك
يا قال
هي
واهش هي فيها
القها
يا فاذا
هي قال
خذ دها سيرتها
الاولى واضمم يدك الى جناحك تخرج بيضاء من
غير سوء ايه اخرى لنريك من اياتنا الكبرى
اذهب الى فرعون
انه طغى قال رب اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي
امري واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه قولي واجعل
لي وزيرا من اهلي هارون اخي
اشدد به امري واشدد به ازري واشركه في
امري كي نسبحك كثيرا ونذكرك
كثيرا
انك كنت بنا
بصيرا قال قد اوتيت سؤلك يا موسى
ولقد
مننا عليك مره
اخرى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله وعلى اله وصحبه ونولا ومن
تبع باحسان الى يوم الدين ان شاء الله
[Silence]
‏asoc
ear حول
اللهصلى عليهه
واللام the was ‏and was more in
10 and make but now that we
needing need prep and more in that اللهب
قدر ليقدر خير من ال
شهر and if you get that
‏worship mon worship and impossible for
us a can life means one night of worship
could bring us to over 83 years of
worship 83
years and we don't know when we the
earth you
know you
know
always home
‏as most you myer passed mon ag
suddenly and the before we all
faceing to othering weing around and the
next we tri
[Silence]
الله
ئش ضي عنى
‏you know sometimes say things
people
us
how
[Silence]
easy
الله
رعاشه
ضي دعام اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العف
‏that bled and
simp
for not compc
make takes make
[Silence]
شاء
الله شا الله
[Silence]
وتال الله سانتال
مج
as you need life
[Silence]
‏as
حشه
are
out ‏we are seing in our
living
job we askal he blesses us with last 10
nights and that he blesses us
with and he gives us the ability to
worship him in that in the true manner
and then he accepts our
salam as they are on the face val that's
it that's it he accepts it as it is
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي
الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب
القبر وقنا عذاب جهنم وكنا شر فتنه المحت
وكنا شر المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل من انك
انت السميع العليم وتب علينا يا مولان
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم امين جزك
الله استقيم اعتدل استو
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين ولقد مننا عليك مره
اخرى اذ اوحينا الى امك ما يوحى انقذ فيه
في التابوت فاقذفيه في اليم فليلقه اليم
بالساحل ياخذه عدو لي وعدو له والقيت عليك
محبه من
ولتصنع على عيني اذ تمشي اختك فتقول هل
ادلكم على من
يكفله فرجعناك الى امك كي تقر عينها ولا
تحزن وقتلت نفسا فنجيناك من
الغم
وفتناك فتونا فلبثت سنين في اهل مدين ثم
جئت على قد يا موسى واصطنعتك لنفسي اذهب
انت واخوك باياتي ولا تنيا في
ذكري اذهبا الى فرعون انه طغى فقولا له
قولا لينا لعله يتذكر او يخشى قالا ربنا
اننا نخاف ان يفرط علينا او ان
يطغى قال لا تخافا
انني
معكما
انني معكما اسمع وارى فاتياه فقولا انا
رسو ربك رب فاتياه فقولا انا رسولا ربك
فارسل معنا بني
اسرائيل ولا تعذبهم
قد جئناك بايه من ربك والسلام على من اتبع
الهدى انا قد اوحي الينا ان العذاب على من
كذب
وتولى قال فمن ربكما يا
موسى قال ربنا الذي اعطى كل شيء خلقه ثم
هدا قال فما بال القرون الاولى قال علمها
عند ربي في
كتا لا يضل ربي ولا
ينسى الذي جعل لكم الارض
مهدا وسلك لكم فيها سبلا وانزل من
السماء
ماء فاخرجنا به
فاخرجنا به ازواجا من نبات شتى كلوا
وارعوا
انعامكم ان في ذلك لايات
لها منها خلقناكم وفيها نعيدكم ومنها
نخرجكم تاره اخرى ولقد اريناه اياتنا كلها
فكذب
وابى قال قال اجئتنا لتخرجنا من ارضنا
بسحرك يا
موسى
فلناتينهم
فاجعل بيننا وبينك موعدا لا نخلفه نحن ولا
انت مكانا سواه قال موعدكم يوم الزينه
وان يحشر
الناس وان يحشر الناس ضحا فتولى فرعون
فجمع كيده ثم
اتى قال لهم موسى ويلكم لا تفتروا على
الله كذبا فيسحتكم
بعذاب وقد خاب من افترى فتنازعوا امرهم
بينهم
واسروا
النجوى فتنازعوا
امرهم بينهم واسروا ال نجوى قالوا انهان
لساحران يريدان ان
يخرجاكم من ارضكم
بسحر ويذهبا
بطريقتكم المثلى
فاجمعوا كيدكم ثم اتوا صفا وقد افلح اليوم
من
استعلى قالوا يا موسى اما ان تلقي
واما ان نكون اول من القاه قال بل
القوا فاذا حبالهم وعصيهم يخيل اليه من سح
سحرهم انها تسعى فاوجس في نفسه خيفه
موسى قلنا لا تخف
انك انت الاعلى والق ما في يمينك تلقف ما
صنعوا
انما صنعوا كيد ساحر ولا يفلح الساحر حيث
اتى فالقي السحره
سجدا قالوا امنا برب هارون
وموسى قال
امنتم له قبل ان اذن لكم انه لكبيركم الذي
علمكم السحر فلو قطعن ايديكم
وارجلكم من
خلاف ولو
صلب في جذوع
النخل
ولتعلمن اينا اشد عذابا
وابقى قالوا لن نؤثرك على ما جاءنا من
البينات والذي فطرنا فاقض ما
انتقاض انما تقضي هذه الحياه الدنيا
انا امنا بربنا ليغفر لنا خطايانا وما
اكرهتنا عليه من السحر والله خير
وابقى انه من يات ربه مجرما فان له
جهنم فان له
جهنم لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا ومن ياته
مؤمنا قد عمل الصالحات
فاولئك
فاولئك لهم الدرجات
العلى جنات عدن
التي جنات عدن تجري من تحتها الان ان
هار وذلك
جزاء من
تزكى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ومن ياته مؤمنا قد عمل الصالحات
فاولئك لهم الدرجات العلى جنات عدن تجري
من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها وذلك
جزاء من
تزكى ولقد اوحينا الى موسى ان اسر بعبادي
فاضرب لهم طريقا في البحر يبسا لا تخاف
دركا ولا تخشاه فاتبعهم فرعون بجنوده
فغشيهم من اليم ما غشيهم واضل فرعون قومه
وما هداه يا بني
اسرائيل قد
انجيناكم من عدوكم
وواعدناكم جانب الطور الايمن
ونزلناه ونزلنا عليكم المن
والسلوى كلوا من طيبات ما رزقناكم ولا
تطغوا فيه ولا تطغوا فيه فيحل عليكم غضبي
ومن يحلل عليه غضبي فقد هواه واني لغفار
لمن امن لمن تاب وامن وعمل صالحا ثم
اهتدى وما اعجلك عن قومك يا موسى قال
قالهم
اء على اثري وعجلت اليك ربي
لترضى قال فاننا فتنا قومك من بعدك
واضلهم
سامري فرجع موسى الى قومه غضبان اسفا قال
يا
قوم قال يا قوم الم يعدكم ربكم وعدا حسنا
افطال عليكم العهد ام اردتم ان يحل عليكم
غضب من ربكم فاخلفتكم
موعدي قالوا ما اخلفنا موعدك
بملكنا
ولكنا حملنا اوزارا من زينه القوم
فقذف فقذف فكذلك القى
السامري فاخرج لهم عجلا جسدا له خوار
فقالوا هذا الهكم واله موسى فنسيه افلا
يرون الا يرجع اليهم قولا ولا يملك لهم
ضرا ولا
نفعا ولقد قال لهم هارون من قبل يا قوم
انما فتنتم به
وان ربكم الله فاتبعوني واطيعوا امري ق
وان ربكم الرح الرحمن فاتبعوني واطيعوا
امري قالوا لن نبرح عليه عاكفين حتى يرجع
الينا موسى قال يا هارون ما منعك اذ
رايتهم
ضلوا الا تتبعني افعصيت امري قال يا ابن
ام لا تاخذ بلحيتي ولا براسي
اني خشيت ان تقول فرقت بين بني
اسرائيل ولم ترقب
قولي قال فما خطبك يا
سامري قال بصرت بما لم يبصروا به فقبضت
قبضه من اثر
الرسول فنبذتها
وكذلك سولت لي نفسي قال فاذهب فان لك في
الحياه ان تقول لا مساس و وان لك موعدا لن
تخلفه وانظر الى الهك الذي ظلت عليه
عاكفا
لنحرقنه
ثم لننسفنه في اليم نسفا
انما الهكم الله لا اله الا
هو لا اله الا هو وسع كل شيء
علما الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين
انما الهكم الله الذي لا اله الا هو وسع
كل شيء علما كذلك نقص عليك من
انباء ما قد سبق وقد اتيناك من لدنا ذكرا
من اعرض عنه فانه يحمل يوم القيامه وزرا
خالدين فيه وساء لهم يوم القيامه
حملا يوم ينفخ في الصور ونحشر المجرمين
يومئذ زرقا يتخافتون بينهم ان لبثتم الا
عشرا نحن اعلم بما يقولون اذ يقول امثلهم
طريقه الا
الا
يوما ويسالونك عن الجبال فقل ينسفها ربي
نسفا فيذرها قاعا
صفصفا لا ترى فيها عوجا ولا امتاه يوم لا
ترى فيها عوجا ولا
امتاه يومئذ لا تنفع الشفاعه الا الا من
اذن له الرحمن ورضي له
قولا يومئذ يتبعون الداعي لا عوج له وخشعت
الاصوات للرحمن فلا تسمع الا
همسا يومئذ لا تنفع الشفاعه الا من اذن له
الرحمن ورضي له قولا يعلم ما بين ايديهم
وما
خلفهم ولا يحيطون به علما وعنت الوجوه
للحي القيوم وقد خاب من حمل ظلما ومن يعمل
من الصالحات وهو
مؤمن فلا
يخاف فلا يخاف
ظلما ولا هضما
وكذلك انزلناه قرانا عربيا وصرفنا فيه من
الوعيد لعلهم يتقون او يحدث لهم ذكرا
فتعالى الله الملك الحق ولا تعجل بالقران
من قبل ان يقضى اليك وحي وقل رب زدني علما
ولقد عهدنا الى ادم من قبل فنسي ولم نجد
له
عزما واذ قلنا
للملائكه اسجدوا لادم فسجدوا الا ابليس اه
فقلنا يا ادم ان هذا عدو لك
ولزوجك فلا
يخرجنكما من الجنه
فتشقى ان لك الا تجوع فيها ولا
تعرى وانك لا تضم فيها ولا
تضحى وانك لا تضما فيها ولا تضحى فوسوس
اليه الشيطان قال يا ادم قال يا ادم هل
ادلك على شجره الخلد وملك لا يبلى فاكلا
منها فبدت لهما
سوءاتهما وطفقا يخصفان عليهما من ورق
الجنه
وعصى ادم ربه فغو ثم اجتباه ربه فتاب عليه
وهداه قال اهبطا من جميعا قال اهبطا منها
جميع عن بعضكم لبعض
عدو فاما
ياتينكم مني هدى فمن اتبع هداي فلا يضل
ولا يشقى ومن اعرض عن ذكري فان له
معيشه
ضنكا ونحشره يوم القيامه اعمى قال رب لم
حشرتني اعمى وقد كنت
بصيرا قال كذلك اتتك اياتنا
فنسيتها
فنسيتها وكذلك اليوم
تنسى
وكذلك نجزي من اسرف ولم يؤمن بايات ربه ول
عذاب الاخره
اشد
وابقى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين افلم يهد لهم كم اهلكنا قبلهم من
القرون يمشون في
مساكنهم ان في ذلك لايات لغل النها ولولا
كلمه سبقت من ربك لكان لزاما واجل
مسمى فاصبر على ما يقولون وسبح بحمد ربك
قبل طلوع الشمس وقبل
غروبها ومن
اناء الليل فسبح واطراف النهار لعلك
ترضى ولا تمدن عينيك الى ما متعنا به
ازواجا منهم زهره الحياه
الدنيا لنفتنهم
فيه ورزق ربك خير وابقى وامر اهلك بالصلاه
واصطبر عليها لا نسالك رزقا نحن نرزقك
والعاقبه
للتقوى وقالوا لولا وقالوا
لولا وقالوا لولا ياتينا بايه من رب
اولم اولم تاتهم بينه ما في الصحف الاولى
ولو انا
اهلكناهم بعذاب من قبله
لقالوا لقالوا ربنا لولا ارسلت الينا
رسولا فنتبع اياتك من قبل ان نذل
ونخزى قل
كل
متربص
فتربصوا
فستعلمون من اصحاب الصراط السوي ومن
اهتدى
الله سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكب الله
اكب
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام علي الس عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شف
استت الله
اكبر الحمد لله لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم ملك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق
فسوى والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى
فاجعله
غثاء
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يغفى ونيسرك
لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت الذكر
سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله
لايلاف
قريش
ايلافهم رحله
الشتاء
والصيف فليعبدوا رب هذا
البيت الذي
اطعمهم من جوع
وامنهم من
خوف الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله اكبر بسم الله الحمد لله
رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله اح
الله
الصمد لم يالد ولم
يد
وف
احد الله
اكبر سع الله
لمن
حمده اللهم انا نشهد انك بانت الله لا اله
الا انت الواحد الاحد الفرض الصمد الذي لم
يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد اللهم انت الحق ووعدك الحق
لقاؤك الحق
وجنه الحق ونار الحق وساعه الحق
ونبي حق ونبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
حق اللهم بك
اسلمنا واليك نبنا وبك
خسم وعليك توكلنا
اغفر لنا ما قدمنا وما
اخرنا فانت المقدم وانت الموخر وانت على
كل شيء
قدير اللهم اهدنا في منن هديت وعافنا في
منن عافيت
وتولنا في منن
توليت وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت انك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يزل
منويت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
اللهم اغفر لنا
ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم تغفر
لنا وترحمنا لكون من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو
عنا اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انك عفو كريم
تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم في ليله هذه المباركه لا تدع
لنا ذنبا الا غفرت ولا هما الا
فرجت ولا دينا الا
قضيت ولا حاجه الا
يصر ولا عدوك الا حلقته
ولا ضالا الا
هيته ولا يسيرا الا
يس ولا ميت الا
رحمت اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار ورقاب
والدينا وذريتنا
وازواجنا وابائنا
وامهاتنا
واخواننا وادخلنا جنه مع الابرار يا عزيز
يا
غفار اللهم نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت به
نفسك او انزلته في كتابك وعلمته احدا من
خلقك وا استاثرت فيعلم غيب عتك انت تجعل
القران ربيع قلوبنا وجلا اذاننا وذهاب
هبونا
وبونا اللهم ذكرنا منه ما
نسينا وعلمنا منه ما جهلنا وارزقنا تلامه
اناء الليل واطراف النهار على وجهك الذي
يرضيك عن النار يا عزيز يا
جبار اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوت
ويا كاسي العذاب الاحم بعد الموت اغفر
لجميع الموت
المسلمين الذين شهدك بالوعد
انيه ونبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافيهم وعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم وم
سيمد قلهم واغسلهم ماء الثلج والبرد ونقيه
من الذنوب والقتا كما ينقى الثوب الابيد
من
الدنس اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدس
اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحزن جندك
سبحانك وبحمدك اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى
الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم اعد المسجد
الاقصى الى ارحاب المسلمين اللهم اعد
المسجد الاقصى الى ارحاب المسلمين
وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل الممات اللهم لا
تردنا بواء خائبين وبابك جندك متردين وصلى
الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله ‏ja